hello everyone and welcome to round one
of the 2018 Alti box Norway championship
now as you all know or maybe some of you
don't before the classic part of the
tournament there was there was a blitz
tournament and although it was very
tense in the end it was Wesley so who
won that event but now we are going to
cover the classic part of the tournament
and already we have a pretty nice game
in round one it's Magnus Carlsen versus
Fabiano Caruana
once again the the duel that will meet
in November to decide the fate of the
World Championship but before we before
we show the game we do want to check out
some of the other contenders so let's
let's meet the contenders that we'll be
fighting for for the title of the Norway
champion in order of appearance here we
have Hikaru Nakamura Wesley Sol
Vishwanathan Anand Fabiano Caruana
Magnus Carlsen Maxime vasila Grove there
Sergei kurakin Shaffir momma dr of Levon
Aronian and of course everyone's
favorite Dingley Rijn the man who who
didn't who simply doesn't lose any games
so definitely interested to see how he
fares in this tournament and once again
before we before we check out this
pretty neat game we do have some photos
sorry we already saw that today we have
Magnus Carlsen and I suppose up with
with a blurry Peter hi Nilsson in the
back his coach then we have a photo from
the beginning of this round shaking
hands with with Fabi
then another one there you have it you
can just enjoy it for a brief moment and
notice in the back that cousin no longer
uses his orange plus plus water
refreshing drink but they all used these
sponsored bottles of water so okay a
very nice close-up and oh this is a very
nice close-up as well of Fabi very nice
and okay this is one I took from from
the live feed so it's not not of the
highest quality all of the photos I will
be using in this Norway Championship are
taken by Leonard Oats he's a
photographer and he said it's okay to
for us to enjoy them so as usual I will
put all of
links to his social media in the
description below I've enjoyed
photography if you enjoyed chase you
know be sure to follow him on all of his
social media so that being said let's
check out this game so Carson versus
Caruana
let's let's go we have E 4 E 5 and
already a very interesting turn of
events on move to across and goes for
Bishop to c4 so avoiding Knight to f3
everyone was kind of hoping to see what
Carson can do against the better of
defense as Caruana is now considered you
know the the top authority on the patter
of defense he basically won the
candidates tournament with it but Carson
avoids it with Bishop to c4 now it's
very interesting why would Carson avoid
it could be that he doesn't think he's
prepared enough to take on Caruana
special defense maybe he doesn't he
doesn't think he could achieve anything
with white against it or maybe he just
doesn't want to show what he has
prepared for November but I think we
will see a lot of Petrov defenses in
November so Knight to f6
we have d3 c6 Knight to f3 and d5 now
Bishop to b3 exchanging in the center
doesn't give white pretty much anything
after captures captures in check black
will simply attack the Bishop Bishop d7
and after captures captures the pawn is
defended black can develop naturally
Bishop c5 Bishop e7 the row can come to
c8 so black would black would enjoy
playing this position very much so
Bishop to b3 we have Bishop to b4 check
Bishop blocks Bishop captures Knight
captures and a5 now Bobby is threatening
a 4 to capture to capture a bishop so c3
making room for the Bishop 9b d7 he
captures on d5 seek after sandy 5 and we
have castles by both sides rook to e1
Carlsen attacks d5 pawn rook to e8
defending and night to f1
preparing either Knight e3 or knife g3
in depending what black plays b5
expanding on the Queen side and a for a
very nice move and you'll see you'll see
how far this a 4 move goes in the long
run b4
C capture some before a capture zombie
4 and 9 3 3 9 2 G 3 also an idea but it
kind of leaves this F 2 point a bit too
weak black could go for something like
Queen b6 and then nice the g4 could
could be very annoying for white so 9 3
3 we're a temple immediately attacking
that d5 pawn bishop to b7 defending and
d4 now and what do you do here here you
could capture he captures Queen captures
nothing really going on there for black
it's a very weak bond white will pretty
much have no problems winning it so
instead we have E for attacking the
knight on f3 and now comes a very nice
move by Carlsen Knight to e5 it seems
like a pawn sacrifice but as you'll see
it is a temporary pawn sacrifice but a
lot of compensation comes with it and
Knight captures we have pawn captures
and rook captures and now Queen d4 a
beautiful centralizing move your queen
and d4 is always a good idea attacking
the rook also the pawn on b4 is not
attacked rook to e7 and now not
capturing the point immediately if you
capture immediately then black couldn't
could gain a lot of initiative with D
for D 3 so instead after lucky seven
first rook 8c one continue development
there's no rush to win death pawn we
have looked to d7 now defending the the
weak d5 pawn look II to the one and now
h6
we have roped the c5 again cousin
doesn't want to win the pawn too soon
heat now he will now pileup on the d5
pawn rook to a5 and now comes roof
captures on a5 again here you could
capture Queen captures but the idea is
the same after rook capture screen
captures d4 is coming after Knight f5 d3
is coming and yeah you allow something
that you know needs not to be allowed so
after Luke a5 rogue captures we have
Queen captures and now h3 making some
breathing room for a king also keeping
an eye on that night on f6
we have King to h7 and now rook to c1 we
have roped the c7 offering a trade rook
captures Queen captures and
now comes Queen Kaptur some before only
now this calls in captured upon and the
material is completely equal now both
sides have a light square bishop a
knight a queen and five points and the
king of course but Carson has a pest a
pond and the pest be pond two connected
passed pawns that's that's that's very
nice
so Queens the c1 check what do you do
here well there are a couple of ways you
can block this the bush would be one
night be one night f1 king h2 if you're
looking H 2 then Queen c7 will simply
repeat 27 Queen c1 so definitely not a
good idea
9 f1 will run into Bishop 286 and now
white is simply lost there is no defense
against Queen captures so after this
Queen to c1 check Bishop to d1 was
played now the queen is also guarding
the b2 upon the bishop is stopping check
and also keeping an eye on that a4 pawn
bishop to a6 preparing Bishop to e2 to
pin the Bishop and Queen d4 we have
Bishop to e2 king h2 and Bishop captures
Knight captures and now comes Queen back
to c7 check King g1 and Queen back to c1
and here calls in place before so as you
can see material is again completely
equal but the best MB pawn do pose a lot
of problems for black so here Caruana
does the thing for a while and he really
got low on time here he plays the
strongest move recommended by the engine
and it's a move that gains a so much
activity for black but you do have to
give up some material he plays III pawn
captures on e3 and not nice to e4 the
idea is nice to d2 and this will block
the Queen's defense of the night we have
Queen captures on d5 grabbing another
point and now Queen to d2 now the night
is no longer protected and Caruana is
threatening to capture it unfortunately
for Fabi the knight cannot be captured
because of Queen to f5 check King h8 and
now Queen to g4 the night is now
defended we have f5 again if you capture
the pawn then Queen captures night so
Queen has to move back
Queen e2 and now nice to e4 and this was
fabi's idea there really wasn't a better
idea I give up
some material but to gain a lot of a lot
of activity but Carlson does have the to
past ponds and he wants to push them
Queenie 1 we have Queen 2 a1 attacking
the a4 pawn
a5 Knight to d6 sorry about that Queen
d2 Knight to c4 attacking the Queen
Queen to b4 offering a trade of Queens
of course you cannot allow trade Queens
you are down two points we have Queen 2
c1
and now King to f1 Knight captures an e3
with Czech Queen captures Queen
characters and now King to F - so now
it's one pawn up but still those are two
connected passed pawns on Queen side
Quincy to check King g3 and g5 now
threatening f4 of course to win the
Queen we have winter leaf I've checked
in to h7 and now King to h2 Fabi pushes
f4 that the threat is now of course f3
so cross and prevents at Queen d5
another beautiful centralizing move the
queen is guarding f3
now the pawns are free to march forward
Queen to a4 now if you wanna if you want
to guard the b-pawn you're gonna have
problems pushing the a pond and then
White Queen will have to get become very
unactive so instead we have Queen check
King moves and Queen to g6 cos and gives
up one pawn on the Queen side to gobble
up pawns on the Kings side Queen capture
some before we have Queen captures on h6
would check King g8 Queen captures and
g5 with check for King h7 and Queen to
h5 check a king moves repeating the
position for a bit King h7 and now H for
all of the pawns are protected so Queen
to d6
some some ideas who is pushing f3 Queen
to h5 check in moves again cousin
repeats a couple of moves and now h5 and
here black who really doesn't have
anything to do Carson will play Queen g6
if the Queen stays here then exchanging
Queens will simply win as the a pawn is
already almost on a 8 and if you avoid
it there's really no counter play h6
Queen Queen g7 is coming so nothing
really to do here on
movies the movie plays that's f3 would
check g3 and now f2 we have 20 g6 check
and now Bobby doesn't capture it rather
he plays King to h8 we have Queen
captures and now Queen to f1 so keeping
the game alive but now it's 3 past
points against zero passed pawns there's
really nothing to do here a queen to h8
check King moves winter e6 check King
moves and now Queen to e3 blocking
blocking any checks Fabi might have in
mind going to be 5 but now again a very
nice idea by Carlson Queen c3 check da
five-point is now guarded King h7 and
now G for a very nice move moves like
Queen to be two now don't really do
anything because after King to g3 notice
that the White Queen is guarding all of
the squares the black Queen might use to
check the White King so there's really
nothing black can do here so after g4
we'd have King Queen to d5 Queen to c7
check for King moves and now King to g3
Queen e6 Queen dat check King h7 and
Queen to d3 check now King moves and now
a 6
the queen is guarding the a pawn front
from d3 very nicely 25 check King moves
we have Queen to a 1 and now Queen to d8
check King moves we have Queen to e7
check King moves Queen III check King
moves and then out comes a 7 again the
queen is a beautifully positioned here
guarding the a7 pawn and it was in this
position that Fabiano Caruana
World Chess Championship challenger
resigned the game why did he resign well
it's pretty obvious there are really no
moves here after after one check Queen
f1 after King g3
there are no more checks to be given
again the White Queen is blocking all of
the squares black and used to check so
yeah after a 7
Fabi resigned the game and a very nice
win for Magnus Carlsen he is in fact the
only one that won a game in round 1 of
the Norway championship so already from
round 1 he's in delete we will be
showing the standings after some other
runs but it's not necessary after round
1 so yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank
Konstantinos mum
Matas matthew client and Marceline
whiskey for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
and I would like to take this
opportunity to wish a happy birthday to
Leopold Gerlach a subscriber of mine his
girlfriend contacted me if I would do
this for his birthday so I thought yes I
will do it of course because you know I
thought it's not like it's not like
asking someone to congratulate you a
happy birthday nothing like that it's I
think as you know we are chess players
and you know you don't really get all
that much in life when you're a chess
player so I don't know I just thought I
would do this so Leopold you know I wish
you all the best in in in chess in
college and in life in general you know
go get him so once again that was the
game I do hope you enjoyed it and yeah
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here think all for watching and I
will see you soon
perhaps with another game from round one
of the norway championship but we'll see
we'll see if there are any any
interesting you know lines that were
hidden that i didn't spot during during
the live coverage so once again thank
you all and I will see you soon